president biden about to speak in his
hometown of scranton pennsylvania he's
trying to sell the public on his
trillion dollar spending plans but new
poll numbers show that not many
americans are buying into it his
approval rating now sinking to just 37
and the independents who carried him to
victory are souring as well with 56
percent now disapproving of the job he's
doing and crisis continue to pile up for
the white house recorded bottlenecks in
the supply chain along with inflation
distressing americans as the prices of
food and gas continue to soar and then
there are shortages like in colorado
where they don't have enough food for
the school lunches leading to other
problems that's happening across the
country harold
why is president biden
traveling to scranton pennsylvania to
make this sales pitch he already has the
senators of delaware on board they're
going to say yes we don't have a job
shortage in america we have other
problems but yet he's just going to go
to scranton
it's home for him i think he's able to
uh convey the message and it's a it's
it's an all-americana surrounding but
your point is your point i take well and
i think is broader uh they are they're
facing a lot of headwinds here they need
a win um it is interesting to me that
there's some democrats who are trying to
provide a path including joe manchin and
kirsten sinema and it seems as if even
bernie sanders may recognize that joe
biden was elected president we've got to
go down a different path
but there are two issues here the
polling and then there's the narrative
around the bill the polling is terrible
and they are intertwined they've got to
get a better narrative like i don't know
you know other than some of the things
that republicans who are opposed to it
what they say is in it and what a few
democrats say is in it but it doesn't it
doesn't all it doesn't have a rhyme and
reason to me we yesterday on this set
talked about i think the most disturbing
story the philadelphia story is
disturbing on another level but a
disturbing story from a policy
standpoint is that china now has the
capacity and technology to make a
missile that can zig and zag and maybe
drop a bomb over an american city
if that's not an organizing principle
for us in the country government leaders
and others say here's what we need to be
doing i don't know what else is i would
implore the white house
i understand where you're coming from
and i like a lot of the things that are
in both the if not all of the things in
infrastructure and some of the things in
the overall reconciliation package but
tied together give us a message give us
a narrative and if you can't do that
those poll numbers they're having a hard
time selling it but here's the thing
jesse when if there's oh this frustrates
me so much in the reconciliation bill
what did president biden say last night
to tell all the people we gotta make
some cuts
because we're not gonna be able to get
3.5 trillion but the one thing that will
not get cut is something from years ago
and that's the increased subsidies for
obamacare so what happens is you give as
progressives like you give an inch
because you know you're going to get the
mile later on because those programs
never go away
the country has a very short attention
span everyone is really busy and if
you're going to sell something if you're
a salesman a politician anybody you have
a window to sell and it has to be simple
you have to tax cuts
obamacare
that's it right it has to be clean
simple and convincing
and joe biden hasn't done that he has
two things he has infrastructure no one
knows what that is and he has
reconciliation more people don't know
what that is no one knows what that word
is not doing it for you and no one knows
what is in the reconciliation bill so
he's taken two things it's too
complicated and people are now obsessed
over the price tag and the process
instead of what am i getting as a
american citizen that you're trying to
sell to me
instead of one thing like tax cuts or
obamacare he has put every single thing
liberals have always wanted to do into
one pot
amnesty for 10 million illegals tax
hikes
green new deal it's irs it's too much
for people to keep track of so he's not
able to close it and it now it doesn't
meet the moment because what do we need
windmills for right now when people are
caring about covid the economy and
illegal immigration those are the top
three concerns of the american people
and you're talking about uh universal
day care
would you trust a baby with the federal
government no and the program's not
going to get off the ground in what two
years three years a tax cut for a child
credit tax cut no one's going to give
joe biden credit for that no one feels
that you sell a wall you see a wall
obamacare we went online and we bought
it say what you want there was something
that you could actually feel none of
this you can feel the other thing is
that the
president biden has tended to
cater to the left because yesterday if
they had that meeting the progressives
were very
gracious and generous and said oh he's
the closer he's the best and the
moderate said nothing no you know what
you guys are all wrong the solution here
is it's our fault
we have to
lower our expectations i like michelle
because it is on us
it's not on joe and how dare we expect
competence from the government right the
overriding message from the white house
for every problem has always been it's
on you america i'm losing my patience
with you america about kovid i'm now
like saying like oh you don't like
waiting in line you don't like empty
empty stores you know what
get used to it all right this uh this is
the argument that prevailed in the
soviet union you didn't like the bread
line don't wait in the breadline starve
i'd wait in the bread line uh america
now has to deal we have to deal with the
decline because the government and the
media is telling us that the decline is
necessary it is not temporary it is
actually deserved the pursuit of
happiness is now an acceptance of fate
and this is how countries
decline and possibly die it's not in a
bloody civil war war it's a revolution
that is sold to you as progress when it
is not if america were a patient they'd
this white house would be happy to
smother it with a pillow and that's a
terrible analogy
but i understood it unlike the other
things that jesse was saying it's hard
to understand katie take us into the
mind of kirsten cinema the senator from
arizona
she's basically been the one that the
democrats are the most mad at they are
very frustrated with her they don't seem
to be as mad at mansion for whatever
reason uh what do you think that she'll
do
well i think that they may be more
frustrated with her because when she was
running for office she seemed like she
was more far left and she was governed
and voted more conservatively since
she's been in office but she's probably
looking at joe biden's poll numbers and
going he is very unpopular in arizona
and that is the state i represent and so
i'm going to represent my constituents
and after the president came out and was
asked it was okay to follow me into the
restroom with a phone and record in the
restroom with harassment and he said
well it's part of the job instead of
condemning it i really have no interest
in kind of helping him get his big
achievement over over the line in terms
of why he's going to scranton i think
he's going there because scranton is
like his security blanket you know he
always talks about it makes him feel
good his poll numbers are really bad he
does need a win
and for a while
the white house tried to blame
republicans for not getting this thing
passed but if you look at the
independents and what they're feeling
about this they can't do that anymore